the united states is eager for sweden
and finland to join nato and strengthen
the alliance but one country is standing
in the way you can convince turkey to
accept their bid
i think i i'm not going to turkey but i
think we're going to be okay
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
traveled to new york to meet with his
turkish counterpart at the united
nations foreign minister melvit
kavasuglu came to express his country's
objections
namely finland and sweden's support for
kurdish nationalist groups that turkey
views as terrorists i'm looking forward
to pursuing that
conversation
today we had
finland and sweden
submit their applications and this of
course is a process and we will work
through that process
as allies and its partners
you know uh tony turkey has been
supporting the open door policy on nato
even before this war but with regards to
these possible
candidates or already candidate
countries you know we have also
legitimate security concerns that they
have been supporting
terrorist organizations turkey also
wants them to lift a weapons embargo
imposed after turkey invaded syria to
attack kurdish groups
the meeting here at the united nations
on the sidelines of a ministerial
conference on food security appeared
cordial both sides expressed confidence
they could work out their differences
but the meeting ended with no
announcement
if any progress was made the turkish
foreign minister kept it to himself
as the u.s remained optimistic we're
confident that at the end of the day
finland and sweden will have an
effective and efficient accession
process that turkey's concerns can be
addressed finland and sweden are working
directly with turkey to do this but
we're also talking to the turks to try
to help facilitate president biden will
meet with his finnish and swedish
counterparts at the white house on
thursday kristin salumi al jazeera the
united nations